yes the amazing spider-man is a reboot
for a new spider-man series I think we
should all get over that man being
honest the amazing spider-man or so the
amazing spider-man is the story about
spider-man you know Peter Parker he was
a nerdy kid in school and then he got
bitten by a radioactive spider and then
it becomes the superhero spider-man
never heard such mixed reviews about
this movie some people love it some
people hate it some people say it's just
ripping off the Sam Raimi movies switch
them to be honest it's a pretty stupid
argument I think that's a stupid
argument it's a spider-man movie Peter
Parker's gonna be a nerdy kid in high
school who gets picked on he gets bitten
by a spider who gets spider like powers
and then something tragic happens in his
life and then he becomes a superhero
spider-man that's just called being
accurate not ripping off a movie that
came decades after the source material
the question is does this movie do
spider-man well doesn't do it justice
and I personally believe yeah I thought
it kicked ass and more than kicked ass
although the actions really cool and I
like to him web slinging but you've seen
web slinging before it is not 10 years
ago where spider-man's cinematography is
just gonna blow you eggs you're like wow
it's almost like this hasn't ever
happened before we've seen most things
that special effects can do so you can't
rely on special effects to bring Wow to
the movie if Wow is a term I that
sounded really pretentious well you
should rely on is the characters being
relatable and having layers to them and
that's where I think this movie really
excel I loved Peter Parker's character
he was a really relatable character and
the thing is right Peter Parker is
always a nerd in high school that's the
story of Peter Parker but what's nerdy
now was not nerdy 10 years ago and that
was not nerdy decades before when
Spiderman was created what is nerdy or
cool and not cool that changes over time
so they made a Peter Parker that I think
will actually last through the decades
he's kind of the quiet kid who sits in
the back of class kind of keeps to
himself and he's really good at science
I'm pretty sure if he didn't become
spider-man he'd become a serial killer
but I think this movie did the character
of Peter Parker justice and I thought he
did gwyn Stacy were really good together
they were really cute they were a cute
couple you by the fact that at first he
has a crush on her but she's nerdy
enough to you know be interested in him
too and then he gets his confidence up
because you know he can break people in
half I mean he doesn't but he could if
you wanted to that'll give you a boost
of confidence that's just realistic and
so I bought that in this movie now one
of the myths about this movie is that
it's
being The Dark Knight because it's
darker I personally don't feel as doing
that in my humble opinion what I do feel
is doing is taking the Peter Parker
spider-man story and making it more
realistic I mean you know the Sam Raimi
movies as much as I enjoyed them will
the first two they were a bit cheesy I'm
just saying you know and it plays
raindrops keep falling on my head and
spider-man two then it all freezes like
a Mentos commercial it made me laugh but
it was cheesy this amazing spider-man
movie is simply taking the cheese out of
it it still does have humor in it but
the humor works it never crosses that
line into cheesy I didn't think and if
they are making it more realistic here's
the realistic truth about life itself
it's a little dark sometimes sorry I
didn't want to be the one to tell you
but sometimes life itself is a bit dark
and the movie doesn't go overboard and
darkness I'm just saying that it does
have dark tones in it sometimes I mean
something really tragic and Peter
Parker's life happens that makes him
spider-man that event was a lot more
tragic in this movie I mean you really
felt it you're like that really sucks
and he deals with it for quite some time
he has a chip on his shoulder he's not
really that responsible with it at first
his superpowers that is he is a bit of a
vigilante the whole like power and
responsibility thing hasn't quite sunk
in because you know that's just how a
teenager would deal with the situation a
teenager's not going to be like Oh Uncle
Ben said be responsible so that's what
I'm gonna do it's gonna be some conflict
with it I mean this is gonna be some
gray areas that he metals in and that's
what I really liked about how they use
spider-man's humor me a Spider Man if
you don't know he's actually pretty
humorous dude you know that scene in the
trailer where he's taking down that one
guy he's like oh you found my weakness
it's small knives the movie illustrates
that spider-man's humor really is a
tactic that he uses that's what he does
there's this one scene where he gets his
powers and before he's spider-man he
humiliates someone and even Uncle Ben's
like that's not how you do it and I
loved how even after you know
spider-man's whole tragedy thing you
know where he's supposed to be
responsible and whatnot he still
humiliates the bad guys because as much
as you want spider-man to be this super
person who's like no I follow Uncle
Ben's teachings to a tee in the end he
is his own guy and he's gonna do what he
does I like that it made spider-man such
a real character for me one thing that I
felt was really wasted in the movie was
the villain the lizard the lizard if you
don't know is this scientist named dr.
Curt Connors and he doesn't have an arm
and so he's splicing animal DNA with
human DNA and he does it with a lizard
and the helps him grow his arm back but
now he becomes this big mutant lizard
that's terrorizing every
they wasted the character because they
had such an opportunity to be like
alright the lizard is the bad guy but
dr. Connors is not no matter what we do
we need to find out how to take out the
lizard but not dr. Connors because he's
a good guy this lizards just a maniac
but they didn't really illustrate that
fact I felt like when he was the lizard
if he just dropped off a building and
splattered on the pavement and died I'd
be like oh sweet well at least that bad
guys taken out chalk one up for the good
guys I shouldn't feel like that with the
lizard there should be some humanity
that you want to preserve I mean maybe
they could have showed dr. Connors with
his wife and kid you know add some
humanity to the character in the end
he's a guy in a lab coat where you're
like alright you're gonna turn into a
bad guy and then we're gonna need to
take you out because that's what good
guys do there are a couple of moments in
this movie - were you like ah you
probably shouldn't have done that in
front of people yeah they all know
you're spider-man now because you just
did that thing that really gives you
away but no one really questions that
they're like oh he just threw that
football and bent that pole no human
being could do that maybe spider-man
could but it's not spider-man we're not
even going to question it I found that a
little weird a little easy the amazing
spider-man had great characters really
exciting moments they developed the
characters well you deal with the
tragedy with Peter Parker - the fact
that they kind of wasted their
opportunity with the lizard and I didn't
find the lizard too compelling I'm going
to say I will buy the amazing spider-man
on blu-ray which I will say this if they
didn't squander the lizard they made him
more of a relevant villain and not just
a hollow CGI thing that Spiderman needs
to fight this movie probably would have
pulled an awesome tacular from me
alright so your favorite spider-man
villain who is he or she whoever they
are comment below let me know and as
always if you like me eating here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you